our Yolanda Hadid exclusive Rachel Smith
joins us from Madame Tussaud's New York
in Times Square Rachel Miss Yolanda has
some things to say oh yes she does
Michelle especially about her time as a
Beverly Hills housewife but we start
with Yolanda's viral moment sparked by
one word almonds I'm feeling really weak
I have a couple of almonds chew them
really well I came out of you know six
hour surgery to remove my breast
implants and Gigi calls I'm not feeling
good and I said take some almonds I
carry almonds in my purse every day not
because I'm on a diet because they level
out my my blood sugars but the world ran
with that as a story that I'm starving
my children well Gigi and Bella's mom
has a sense of humor about it all she
just went viral with this Tick Tock clap
back hashtag worst mom ever you've said
that being a part of a reality show took
a toll on your mental health sorry is
not enough you said it well the first
season I went on I was diagnosed with
you know neurological Lyme disease and
you know a lot of narratives that were
created by the women but those things
were very hurtful I was fighting for my
life what do you think of the situation
that Kathy Hilton currently finds
herself in in her feeling bullied you
are the biggest this bully in Hollywood
I feel sorry for Kathy because I've been
in her shoes I feel sorry what it does
to her family with Kyle and Kim and you
know it's it goes deep right and why
because you want camera time we were
with Yolanda on world mental health day
at Hudson yards in New York she declined
to speak on the reports that Gigi is
dating Leo DiCaprio instead she wanted
to keep the focus on Project Healthy
Minds I feel that we need to be able to
speak about these things openly and
freely what have you taught your
daughters about mental health especially
leading lives in the spotlight I've
always taught them be good to everybody
because people don't remember what you
look like but they will remember how you
make them feel what is bringing you the
most joy in life these days the most Joy
is my granddaughter Kai I feel like you
know she's my mom came back in this
little miniature
incredible little human being like she
does things I'm like oh my God that's my
mom
foreign